they put a lot of systems in the system
it's in the game to make it more casual
without taking away from the core of
experience and that's what I like when
developers do they look at something
they're like look
this system likes this people like this
we we don't want to interrupt like it's
like from software with the you know
difficulty setting we don't want to put
a difficulty setting in it because we
know our casual audience don't want this
okay so what we're going to do we're
going to make we're going to make a
fortitude system to where if you get all
of those flags and reward you for
exploration you're going to come in
there and you're going to body everyone
but the boss but if you want to you know
make yourself a challenge you can go in
there and fight a matter too go ahead
you'll probably get clapped but you can
try